wir sind heute im johannes paul der
zweite gymnasium in toren
heute zeigen wir euch die präposition
auf jetzt seht ihr verschiedene
beispiele
wann man die präposition benutzt
[Musik]
kreispokal
ja
kuba liegt auf dem tisch
kalli wo hast du die bilder gespeichert
das weiß ich mich entweder auf dem
laptop oder auf dem stick auf der treppe
gibt es fußabdrücke die mädchen liegen
aber dem atlas monika steht auf dem kopf
auf meine uhr ist es schon viertel nach
sechs ich muss weg wie schnell fällt
liegen auf der bank der ball liegt im
tor
wenn ich diesen scheck einlösen habe ich
5000 zloty auf dem konto auf dem bild
sieht man einen fahrradfahrer auf dem
schild ist ein kreis in polen ist das
ein zeichen für ein frauen klo
wir sitzen auch wärmer wir tanzen auf
der wiese mein autor spät auf dem
parkplatz kuba und zimmern springen auf
die mütze über klettert auf die laterne
die leute stehen auf der wiese und
warten worauf wartest du
ich warte darauf dass meine schüler
perfekt deutsch sprechen
worauf wartest du ich warte auf ein
wunder
worauf wartest du ich warte auf das
andere auftretende wagen worauf wartest
du ich warte auf meinen geburtstag
worauf wartest du
ich warte auf die sommerferien
und worauf wartest du ich wollte afrika